CHARLES: BACK WITH THE FOX NEWS
ALERT AS RUSSIA LEVELS UKRAINIAN
CITIES KAMALA HARRIS MAKES AN
INTERESTING MISTAKE IN A PLEDGE
TO DEFEND UKRAINE.
LISTEN.
>> I WILL SAY OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, THE UNITED STATES STANDS
FIRMLY WITH UKRAINIAN PEOPLE IN
DEFENSE OF THE NATO ALLIANCE.
>> SHE SAID IN DEFENSE OF THE
NATO ALLIANCE.
THE PROBLEM IS UKRAINE IS NOT
NATO, WAS THAT A MISTAKE OR ON
PURPOSE, THE WHITE HOUSE
CHANGING THE TRANSCRIPTS WHICH
WE HAVE HERE TO READ THE UNITED
STATES STANDS FIRMLY WITH
UKRAINE PEOPLE AND IN DEFENSE OF
THE NATO ALLIANCE.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THAT AND YOU
LOOK HERE AS WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED
THE AND GOT ADDED IN.
CHARLIE HURT, WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE, IT IS INSANE.
CHARLES: SHE'S OUT OF HER DEPTH
WHEN SHE GOES OVER TO EUROPE AND
STARTS TALKING ABOUT THIS STUFF,
SHE IS UNSAFE AT ANY SPEED
OBVIOUSLY PROPAGANDA AS PART OF
ANY WAR THAT'S WHEN POLITICIANS
SAY IN THE MIDDLE OF WAR IS
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT AND
IMPORTANT THAT THEY GET IT
RIGHT, THE BUSINESS OF SAYING
ONE THING AND THE WHITE HOUSE
TRYING TO CLEAN IT UP FURTHER
UNDERMINES HER CREDIBILITY AND
THERE'S A LOT OF HANDWRINGING
ABOUT THE U.S. DOING MORE IN THE
DEFENSE OF UKRAINE.
I TELL YOU A BIG REASON WHY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT DOWN
WITH THAT, THEY SIMPLY DO NOT
TRUST AS A ADMINISTRATION TO
CARRY OUT ANYTHING THAT IS
DANGEROUS.
WHEN YOU GET THINGS LIKE THAT
LIGHT KAMALA HARRIS, IT IS
HIGHLIGHTED AND UNDERSCORED
D
MAKES PEOPLE LOSE ALL THAT MUCH
MORE CONFIDENCE.
>> WE ARE PLAYING VIDEO OF HER
STANDING NEXT TO THE POLISH
PRESIDENT WHERE SHE LAUGHED.
YOU COVERED INTERNATIONAL EVENTS
OF WORLD LEADERS, SHOULD THEY
HAVE NOT UPSET HER FROM THIS
ROLE, WAS THIS A MISTAKE.
>> IT'S INTERESTING WHAT THEY
CHOOSE TO SEND HER TO DO INTACT
HER WITH.
USUALLY A LOT OF THINGS THEY
DON'T WANT TO DO THEMSELVES.
THEY PUT IT ON FRIENDLY
SITUATIONS AND SHE APPEARS TO
NOT REALLY BE READY FOR IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS INTO
CHARLIE'S POINT YOU ASK YOURSELF
AGAIN, THESE ARE THE DIPLOMATS
THAT ARE REPRESENTING THIS
COUNTRY, IT SCARES ME INTO
RACHEL'S POINT THAT SHE MADE
YESTERDAY, I LOOKED BACK AND I
WISH WE COULD REWIND A LITTLE
BIT.
I WISH WE WERE NOT HERE HAVING
THEM MAKE THESE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS.
I WISH THEY WOULD'VE CONSIDER
PUTTING SANCTIONS IN PLACE
BEFORE THIS GOT OUT OF CONTROL
BEFORE AN INVASION STARTED TO
LET VLADIMIR PUTIN KNOW THAT WE
WERE SERIOUS BUT THEY WERE
SCARED AND THEY THOUGHT THAT
WOULD ESCALATE THINGS AND SPEED
UP THE TIMELINE.
WE DO NOT HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL TO
SEE WHAT WOULD'VE HAPPENED IF
THEY PLAYED US A DIFFERENT WAY.
THE WAY THAT WE ARE WATCHING A
PLAY OUT IS CERTAINLY SCARY FOR
US ON THE GROUND ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CHEMICAL
WEAPONS AND NUCLEAR WEAPONS,
THIS IS NOT A JOKE.
>> SHE ALSO MADE SOME COMMENTS
SPEAKING AHEAD OF THEM IN TERMS
AND WHAT DEMOCRATS SHOULD SAY TO
VOTERS BEFORE THE NOVEMBER
MIDTERM HERE'S A LOOK AT WHAT
SHE SAID.
RACHEL I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO
GET YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> OUR TASK IS TO SHOW PEOPLE
THAT IN MANY WAYS THEY GOT WHAT
THEY ORDERED.
RIGHT?
THEY SAID THIS IS WHAT THEY
WANTED.
THEY STOOD IN LINE, THEY TOOK
TIME FROM WORK, IT WAS DIFFICULT
AND A LOT OF WHAT THEY DEMANDED,
THEY GOT.
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT THEY ASKED
FOR RECORD INFLATION OUT OF
CONTROL CRIME IN A BORDER ON
FIRE BUT MAYBE I AM WRONG.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT MOST OF US
VOTED FOR BUT LET'S FACE IT THIS
IS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ORDERED,
PART OF IT GOES BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL PROBLEM THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT WHY IS SHE THERE WHEN WE
KNOW SHE'S NOT QUALIFIED, THIS
IS A BIGGER QUESTION FOR AMERICA
AS WE ARE LIVING IN THIS EQUITY
AND DIVERSITY WAY OF HIRING
PEOPLE, THE OFFICE OF THE VICE
PRESIDENT THE CABINET OF THE
PRESIDENT, THESE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT JOBS THAT SHOULD NOT
BE RELEGATED TO PEOPLE JUST
BECAUSE THEY ARE A CERTAIN SKIN
COLOR OR A CERTAIN GENDER OR A
POLITICAL IDENTITY THAT IS
FASHIONABLE RIGHT NOW, WHAT SHE
SAID IS VERY DANGEROUS, IT
COULD'VE LED TO WAR, WE NEED TO
RETURN TO AMERICA WERE
ACHIEVEMENT IN A MERIT-BASED WAY
OF ACHIEVEMENT AND THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING AND I DON'T WANT TO
SINGLE OUT KAMALA HARRIS, DOES
ANYBODY THINK LLOYD AUSTIN IS
THE VERY BEST THAT WE HAVE FOR
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE OR OUR
SYSTEM DOES NOT FIRE PEOPLE WHEN
THEY SCREW UP LIKE GENERAL
MILLEY, THAT COULD MEAN
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, THE SHOULD
OF BEEN FIRED AFTER AFGHANISTAN
AND NOW THEY'RE LEAVING THE
MILITARY RESPONSE AND THE
CRUCIAL TIME FOR THIS COUNTRY,
THIS IS MAKE OR BREAK FOR
UKRAINE WE NEED TO GET BACK TO
MERIT-BASED HIRING AND ITS AWAY
FROM THESE POLITICS AND PUT IN
THE VERY BEST, WE HAVE AMAZING
COUNTRY AND HIRE THE BEST.
>> I HEAR YOU ON YOUR CRITICISM
ACROSS THE ADMINISTRATION AND
PERHAPS DEFENSE SECRETARY A
DISCUSSION FOR ANOTHER DAY BUT
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO HARRIS,
LET ME ASK YOU WE JUST SAW A
RETOOLING OF HER CALM SHOP
BECAUSE SHE DID NOT HANDLE WELL
THE BORDER JOB THAT SHE GOT,
THEY WERE GOING TO TRY AND READ
THAT IF YOU WILL IF YOU SEE IN
WASHINGTON IT DOESN'T SEEM THAT
THAT IS WORKING.
>> I THINK WE ARE STARTING TO
SEE A LOT OF OTHER DEMOCRATS
ESPECIALLY IN CONGRESS WHO ARE
WAKING UP TO THE POLLING THAT
THEY SEE FOR NOVEMBER AND THEY
FACE VOTERS THIS YEAR WERE
KAMALA HARRIS AND JOE BIDEN DO
NOT.
I THINK WERE STARTING TO SEE
BETWEEN DEMOCRATS WHO ARE UP FOR
REELECTION IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE GET TO SEE MORE DAYLIGHT AS
TIME GOES ON.
THE THING THAT IS REALLY
FRUSTRATING EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE
A CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS LEADING A DISASTROUS
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN, YOU DON'T
HAVE A WHITE HOUSE THAT SEEMS
OPEN TO CHANGING POLICIES, YOU
DON'T HAVE A WHITE HOUSE THAT
SEEMS SERIOUS ABOUT ADDRESSING
THINGS LIKE INFLATION, LIKE GAS
PRICES AND ANY SORT OF RATIONAL
INTELLIGENT OR EVENHANDED KIND